[music]
My name is Vera Kuklina
I am a professor at George
Washington University in Washington
DC I was born and raised in a Buryat
village in the Uster DNS Autonomous Okrug
and studied at school then studied at a boarding school for 2 years
because in our school
only incomplete secondary education and
then at the Faculty of Geography of
Irkutsk State University
in
Irkutsk, from the university I entered
graduate school at the Institute of
Geography of the branch of the Russian Academy of
Sciences. There I received a PhD
in geography and worked until
2022 in
fact. That
is, I was affiliated with the institute but
moved
to the USA in 2013 for family
reasons, that's why my career
only started here. Well, it officially began in
2019 when I received my first
Informal Roads Grant. That is,
it is a National Science Foundation Grant
and of course It was based mainly on
my previous research that I
spent in
[music]
Russia
Well, probably it wasn’t
entirely purposeful because in
fact, I had one aunt who was an
economist and worked at
Sberbank. In the nineties, it was, of
course, a completely
different standard of living than what was
in the village and I wanted to follow  in her footsteps,
but I applied to two universities, one
was specifically on auditing and financial
accounting. At the Academy of Economics, but there
was a huge competition and I didn’t get in, but the
second option was the
Faculty of Geography, where it was written that this was
economic social geography, so I
decided that if somehow...  it’s related to
economics, maybe in the future I
will be able to steer in a field, but in the end, when
I arrived at the university and
after the first year we went to And
what do we call it,
we had a field practice on Arshan That
is  these are the Sayan mountains, we went hiking there,
looked at different
geomorphological forms,
hydrologists and looked at how people live
in the
field, work in the tourism sector, and
how this provides them with
sources of income. So I realized that
geography is much more interesting than
economics, and I’ve continued since then,
of course  my favorite pastime is
traveling. And when there is an
opportunity to combine business with
pleasure, it is, of course, doubly pleasant
[music]
Well, I still remain a geographer
and it’s just that
when I
focus more on my cultural
heritage, then the perception of the world as a
whole Yes, in integrity, then  it, of course,
leads to the
understanding
that it is impossible
to explain all of reality only with the help of maps. Well, either with the
help of only the analysis of social
relations or only the hydrology of
geomorphology and the like, this is what
in order to really get closer to
understanding reality. We
need to cooperate with
representatives  different disciplines with
local residents with artists in order to
use all of our
firstly senses, secondly
our knowledge and in general all our emotions, all
this is very important In order to be
more in tune with what is
happening now in the
world
[music  ]
Of course, my main method
is still field observations. That is, this is a
journey just into the
community of
interviews and
discussion of different materials. Now I
try very hard to work
with other
specialists. The circle is very wide,
that is, when we had an expedition,
for example,
in that  in the twenty-first year
Our last expedition we had
a geomorphologist, a cartographer,
looked at how landscapes are described. That is,
when a person sits in a room, the interview
happens in one way. But if you
are on the street. If you see
the landscape, if you react to the
landscape, then the interview happens in a completely
different way.  because there is an opportunity
to talk about the experience that
we share with a person because there is
a
lot of interaction with the landscape, they
[music] are
non-verbal, our project is called
informal roads and it is still
ongoing, this is the final year.
Therefore, there is just an
opportunity  demonstrate how it has been
progressing for almost 5 years from
2019 to
2024 That is, this is a project about Roads
that do not officially exist on
maps If you
look at the usual map that
exists Yes, here is the usual argiz
map argiz is the
main main tool that
our
geographers use. You see here almost  there is nothing, a
pure space without any
markings,
but if we start there, well, that is,
she won’t really show us anything,
so we have to find the roads
that exist in the forest in the taiga ourselves
and show what impact they have
on the natural environment
and for that  to show this,
we go on expeditions and in the place of
Korti we put all this dots, we use
GPS
to accurately record on the terrain
where we are moving, for example,
this road doesn’t actually exist.
But we didn’t draw it because it
doesn’t exist on the official  maps,
but in reality it was created by forestry
companies. That is, we work with
different tools. Which are available
to our partners. Well, that is, we make
field notes on the movement of the campaign. And this is what is
then used to analyze this
territory, that is, I showed that there
are no roads on official maps  but you
see that even if you simply
zoom in on a regular Google map, you can
see that here we have
oil production going on, here there is
deforestation and there are a lot of
areas where
seismic exploration is going on, that is, the
forest is being cut down for
fossils, this has a very big impact
on ecosystems  and uh
the creation of a network of a very uh dense network of
roads, well, those that we call
informal roads. And of course,
based on these maps, we
can then make assessments of the environmental
impact of the social impact there are
problems of poaching. Problems of uh
fires that are associated with the development of
roads. We describe this in  in our various
articles and look at how the
landscape is changing under this
influence and in connection with climate change on the
Internet, the effects of roads and climate are superimposed on each other
and
increased degradation of landscapes is occurring
to a wide audience, we are still working
together with artists here, I just
wanted to show because  it’s
clear that not only is there
cartographic material, but
we also traveled with a photographer who
recorded what we saw along the way. Well, it’s a
way to convey to the widest possible
audience what’s happening in Tag and how
it can affect life in other
parts of the world and
We  created for an informal group Arn
is Ar, that is, art, science, local and
indigenous knowledge, here is our project,
informal roads. Where you can also
read more about
[music]
of course, the main producer of
space images is our nas, that is,
their satellite NT and  there’s just a
wide spectrum. You can
see what different waves there are and
how they are recorded by different satellites.
But with Van Sat the problem is that
the resolution is very low. That is, it’s 30 m
one pixel. That is, you imagine a
one pixel screen. Yes, and it’s 30 m if
we want
it’s much more difficult to find them on
such images, that’s why we turn
to
commercial maxar images. That is,
before it was Digital GL, they use
goi worldview, space images that
have a resolution of 40 cm 30 cm, that is, you
go to maxar and type Where are you  do you want to
work, that is, I have highlighted my
research region and it gives me all
the images that are in this region, that
is, we show that we do not need
cloudy images and there is a
date, there is a specific satellite that at
that time flew over this territory
each  the picture weighs about 11 gigabytes, that is,
Mar, these commercial photographs
have been there since 2002, if we want to
see what happened before then, unfortunately, we
only have which years are
flying and
there are pictures that were
taken by
spy aerial photography,
now all these pictures are posted on Earth
Explorer is a uss site and here you can
just go and find that is, there is
declassified data here and what
you can find in this data
What spy planes flew
over our territory in the
sixties, their resolution was about 2 m That
is, this is a very good resolution  These are the
pictures. Unfortunately, they are paid, but there are
about 60 dollars per picture, we highlight our
card. And then on this card we
are trying to show which ones we
chose, these pictures and
the results. Yes, and he is now looking for what
pictures there are in this particular square.
then, for example,
this picture Yes, it shows where
this overflight happened in what
year and well, and other data, but they are
black and white. But on the other side the roads are
still visible on them, so we
had the opportunity to compare what happened in
the sixties  the seventies with the fact that
now, how everything
has changed, and this requires, of course,
enormous efforts in order to show,
first of all,
VOX to show all these changes, so it
was no longer enough work from their
employees alone and we resorted to the
help of humanitar soci, which we have in
University is based This group But in
fact, it
works all over the world, you can say
that they hold a mafo gathering of
20-30 students who eat
pizza and
potatoes, everything that is necessary, that is,
hurricanes, for example, when they happen or
some other natural disasters Well or
as in my case, this is what we needed to do:
map tofi roads, so we held such a
Mafon
and used the work of students
to make such a map and then
this map will be posted
in Open so that it would be accessible to a
wide
range of
[music]
audience
Fro is interdisciplinary  The transnational
project that we are
developing in cooperation between
universities is George
Washington University University of New Hampshire
A quiet Alaska Pacific University
Alaska University of Alaska Fairbanks
University of Northern Iowa University of
Arizona
and each university has approximately
its own tasks But in fact, there is an
intersection and  we depend on each other to
conduct our field research in
conducting analysis because
this is exactly what we are talking about
transsnab
knowledge here hydrology needs to
understand the quality of snow and ice and
in order to ask questions of local
residents and then asking questions of local
residents receiving from  they have some answers,
we must again turn to hydrological
methods in order
to find out their position and we
again use space images to
see,
we use modeling to
predict what will happen in the future
and
our models
should ideally include not only scientific but
and models of ideas of indigenous people
about what is happening
with snow, permafrost and ice and how
this can affect their future
well-being on the landscapes on their
way of life on how
they position themselves; risks also arise
due to the fact
that the natural conditions they become
less
predictable, that is, people are accustomed to
relying on
their long-term observations, but it
turns out that at present these
observations are not always correct because
suddenly some natural
disasters happen, fires intensify,
some floods intensify, and all this, of course,
creates enormous stress
and this is necessary  understand in order to
plan what to do in the future in order to
try to adapt to
these
climates for the general public this is
important because
we people in the Arctic
were the first witnesses of
such tremendous changes. I would say
and in the future we can only expect that all
this will happen not only  in the Arctic
But also throughout the planet in all regions,
therefore We learn from local
communities how to adapt,
how to exist in new conditions And
of course
we learn how to prevent such
further climate changes. Probably
this is the main task of us as scientists
to show Why  can lead to our
current state of affairs, where
some people still doubt
climate change, doubt that
humans influence it
and get
documentary confirmation, get
scientific confirmation and confirmation from
local residents, this is of course I
hope that it will also help change
this
paradigm of thinking
[  music]
people We live in cities, we live
surrounded by comfort, and people who
live in such remote places
who experience
the consequences of climate change, that is, it
was just a huge shock for me.
When I first arrived in the Katan
region in the north of the Irkutsk region, the village of Tokh is
just this  is located in the Katan
region and Why do I still continue to
try to continue to
live a traditional way of life? They
are in the taiga sometimes for a month,
sometimes more and do not depend
on the shops there or any amenities and
live in such harmony with the world Yes, but
here  foresters come to them,
geologists come and begin to cut down the forest, and
local residents see how all this
affects the landscape and see how
new phenomena are starting now,
for example, like zombie fires, which they have
never seen before, they are simply
horrified by it  that now this is
how the peat bogs burned in Moscow. You
probably remember. But in Siberia
this didn’t happen before because we
had permafrost that protected us from these
fires and now, due to the fact that
climate change is happening due to the fact
that this is happening  these clearings And the abomination is
destroyed and the fire goes not only
in breadth but also in depth, and these are already
irreversible
consequences. And I also traveled
in the mountains. I went to Tofalar, to
sites to Tuvans, then jeans, these are people
who live in Well, also in such  the same
harsh conditions are similar to those in the Arctic
because they are at altitude. And the
glaciers are melting there and what does this mean for their
traditional way of life, which
depends on reindeer; this, of course, is
also a disaster because in the tundra
people are now moving north for
colder conditions  conditions, that is, the deer
need it to be more or less cold and
in the summer they need to escape from mosquitoes
in these glaciers in the snow. And every
year there are
fewer and fewer glaciers in the snowfields, that is, the deer do not know
where to go; they suffer from all this;
with
these indigenous peoples
also being under threat
[music] of
extinction, Baikal, of course, is the
Central part of all our interests
in the region and is a Holy Lake for our
culture. It still attracts not
only tourists but also
religious pilgrims. Because it
is considered a place of power.  and well, in
fact, of course, this is a unique phenomenon
when 1/5 of the world's
fresh water reserves are concentrated and a huge
number of different species of
endemics are concentrated and the fact that it is still growing
every year, it increases by 4 cm That
is, it still continues to develop  and it is
still unknown what surprises there
will be in the future. The Angara is in fact
the only river that flows from
Baikal. And here, too, there is still a big
problem with the fact that there are
hydroelectric power stations on the Angara. That is, in
fact, especially in Buryatia, scientists believe
that Baikal is  is no longer a natural
system but an artificial one because the
level of Lake Baikal
is controlled by this GS, to what extent they
decide to raise the level or lower the
level, that is, there is a law on Lake Baikal
and it directly states within what limits the
level of Lake Baikal can be regulated.
That is, it really is so
complex  man-made system and that because
this platinum was built, Of
course, there was a lot of
destruction along the shore, that is, erosion due to the fact
that the water level rose. Well, that is,
imagine, in any
place where platinums are built,
flooding occurs and here on Lake Baikal  this also
happened in the fifties
[music]
Well, in fact, it depends, of course, it
depends very much. Probably on
political will because the main
polluters are not tourists after all, we
had the Baikal Lioznoe Paper Mill,
which only closed years ago
Since then, there is a risk of contamination
due to the fact that all this waste is stored in
these sludge storage tanks, if
they end up in the lake, it will be an
environmental
disaster, of course, the fact that there is a railway
running right along the shore of
Lake Baikal and the fact that they are also going to
cut down the forest there  On the shore of Bike, this sun
will have an impact much stronger than
tourists. Well, tourists, of course, would like
it to be more of an
eco-tourism, and here
there is
also such a thing that on Lake Baikal. I
already said that the Buryats are the
indigenous population.
But they are forbidden to engage in traditional
fishing.  It is forbidden to
eat omul It is forbidden to engage in
agriculture That is, the fact that they were
traditionally engaged in cat breeding
and
now the Armed Forces turned out to be prohibited,
of course, compared to other
countries, it seems to me that it is simply
unacceptable, that is, it turns out that we are in the
same situation
as there are such
discussions in the colonial  tourism when
people
take away some resources as a prize, yes In this
case,
recreational and the local population
does not receive any profit from this,
mainly large tourist
organizations - these are, of course, not local,
most often the offices are located somewhere in
Moscow or St. Petersburg and of course
they hire  also not locals, that is, for but
locals. As a result, they end up in the public
space
as they are shown as some kind of
culprits for the fact that the lake is being polluted
and the
like [music] the Russian language was important in our
projects that were carried out on the
territory of Russia in order to
conduct interviews  firstly,
secondly, to be able to read in
Russian because there are a lot of sources
that have not been translated into English
and Although my students use
different translators there and they are getting
better and better Well, in the sense of
translator programs, but
unfortunately still understanding  context,
understanding of the nuances is of course lost and
for them it is sometimes difficult to understand
some words
that the translator literally
translates, but it turns out that this is not at all what
people were talking about, so
this is of course a big plus. And in general, knowledge of
languages ​​is a big plus Well, that is, for
The Arctic is
especially because we have half of the
Arctic in Russia and we need to understand what is
happening there in order to build
some kind of climate models in order
to correctly predict
future changes, that is, on the one
hand, of course, we have humanitarian goals
that we
need to exchange  knowledge to share
experience But on the other hand, even in a purely
technical scientific field, it turns out
that it is impossible to make real
forecasts, it is impossible to make real
models, it is impossible to generally assess the
situation in the Arctic without knowledge of the
Russian context, that’s why On the
one hand, even being abroad
But here we have  I myself am from Russia,
we have a lot of colleagues who are from Russia and
who speak Russian in
order to specifically study Arctic
issues in the polar circus
[music]
context of the book,
probably Although it depends on the film, also on the
book
[music]
probably
important for me The book -  this is a man at
Baikal written by Irina Urbana Eva
because she is a researcher who
just drew attention to the issues of
environmental ethics among people living on
Baikal and she does not make much distinction
between different ethnic groups.
She believes that if you have an ethical
relationship then it doesn’t matter who  you are by
nationality And this is how you know
how to build relationships with the world I
think this is a very deep thought and I
think this book is very relevant I don’t
know if it is on the Internet but I highly
recommend it
[music]
probably the main advice is not to be afraid to
dream Because  if you have
ambitions and some kind of goal,
then in small steps you can achieve
literally everything
you want. Well, of course, you need to be open
and I think it’s very important
to have
your own
position that will not depend on
fashion, on any trends, on
political views. Because  that when
you approach the perception of the world of
problems with, you can say from a clean slate,
then you can see a lot more than
if you have some kind of
[music]
blinders. It seems to me that overconsumption is a
problem, that is, if we all learn to
somehow live in accordance
with  with some kind of needs
that are not
excessive, if we understand that
any of our purchases, any of our
decisions, they affect the
chain of
climate change,
then I think that this is
very important at the individual level
to be more aware
[music]
consumers of Baikal, of course.
If you haven’t been to Baikal, then you simply have
no idea what Russia is and well,
[music]
doesn’t